when I started Microsoft I didn't think
of it as all that risky I mean I was so
excited about what we were doing it's
true I could have gone bankrupt
but you know I had a set of skills that
were highly employable and in fact my
parents were still willing to let me go
back to Harvard and finish my education
if I wanted to the thing that was scary
to me wasn't quitting and starting the
company it was when I started hiring my
friends and they expected to be paid and
then we had customers who went bankrupt
customers that I'd counted on to come
through and so then I got this
incredibly conservative approach that I
wanted to have enough money in the bank
to pay a year's worth of payroll even if
we didn't get in heat any payments
coming in if you're gonna start a
company it takes so much energy that you
know you it better overcome your your
feeling of risk you know if you're young
it's hard to go lease premises they made
that hard for me you couldn't rent a car
when you were under 25 at the time so I
was always taking taxis to go see
customers people would you know people
say well we're gonna go have a
discussion in the bar well I go to the
bar you know that's fun because I'll
tell you when people are first skeptical
and then go this kid doesn't know
anything then when you show them you've
really got a good product and you know
something they actually tend to go
overboard and they think whoa you know
they know a lot let's really do an
incredible amount with these people that
those those problems that come with
starting the firm you better think of
those as as part of the the pleasure
part of the the challenge that that is
part of the the excitement I I'm a weird
dropout because I take college courses
all the time I love learning I love
being a student I feel it was
unfortunate that I didn't get to stay
there but I don't think I missed any
knowledge because you know whatever I
needed to learn I would I was still in a
learning mode you just watched two
amazing clips with Bill Gates take the
next three minutes and sit quietly and
think about how you can apply them to
your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]